en este barrio de gas a los trabajos de
remoción de escombros continúan los
obreros activan sus excavadoras pero los
esfuerzos son enormes allí un edificio
entero se cayó en un ataque aéreo
israelí
tres meses después de la guerra el
enclave palestino intenta reconstruirse
y la desesperación se apodera de las
víctimas
si mañana comienza a llover qué vamos a
hacer el invierno se acerca y tenemos
que reconstruir nuestras casas no
queremos dinero sino que vengan a
arreglar todo esto
muchas familias de la zona temen revivir
la misma situación que en 2014 donde la
ofensiva israelí dejó un paisaje de
devastación la reconstrucción duró años
después de las destrucciones ni siquiera
recibimos 100 dólares de su parte
solo tendrían que haber venido hasta
constatar los daños ellos mismos
para reconstruir las rutas los
hospitales y las habitaciones dañadas
elicabe necesita al menos 400 85
millones de dólares
todas sus esperanzas se encuentran
actualmente en los países de la región
esperamos que se abran las fronteras con
el fin de hacer entrar los fondos para
la reconstrucción
egipto se comprometió a enviar 500
millones de dólares qatar también
prometió 500 millones de dólares y otros
países deberían enviar ayuda como kobe
tanto y arabia saudita la última
escalada del conflicto tuvo un enorme
impacto sobre la economía de la franja
de gaza y sus 2 millones de habitantes
las pérdidas se calculan alrededor de
los 200 millones de dólares